uh all right let's go next to
uh where do we want to go there's some
interesting folks and there's some
dangerous
folks to talk to let's briefly speak to
justin from the united kingdom justin
from the uk you're on the air
hello do you hear me i do hear you all
right david
good to speak to you likewise um i was
actually born in chicago
in the united states okay um but all my
life in
the uk so you've only it seems like
you've only taken on
a slight british accent yeah my dad's
american and i
listen to a lot of unifying american
folks so got it
you know i think i've adopted some of
the twine
as it were i was wondering
when you guys are gonna sort out your
[ __ ] if you know what i mean because
you know i'm living here in the uk i
have the paradise of uh
free healthcare whenever i want it right
no problems and one day you know i'd
like to move to the us and uh
make good use of that citizenship that i
have but from the outside looking in
it's a bit like
in some in some ways it's a a bit of a
third world country
is it specifically the health care thing
that's what's making you hesitate
i guess it's a thought it's not not just
the healthcare it's the healthcare
it's the complete lack of paid vacation
days
let's say i have a family in the future
and i want to have a kid
i don't want to have to pay money to
have a child you know and have
potentially higher infant mortality
rates than i would have here
you mean let me see if you're saying
lack of paternity leave
not necessarily only pretend to leave
but i'm speaking also for you know
the women of the world um and that any
partner i might have
would not be able to avail themselves of
that maternity leave and the
lack of paid vacation days is a serious
maybe there's this is just a genuine
misunderstanding but you know the the
truth is that in the united states
things are very very much tiered and
there there
are tiers of jobs where uh there's
plenty of paid vacation
and uh insurance is is
good enough i mean the problem is that
there's such an equality that you have
neighborhoods that are five miles apart
where the circumstances are dramatically
different for
i hate to say this but if you were to
come to the united states
with a good job waiting for you you get
paid vacation
paid maternity leave uh relatively
modest health insurance contributions i
mean
what's horrible about the system is that
it does work quite well
for people in in certain jobs and it's
an absolute
embarrassing disaster for people and
others i i hate to admit that
um but you know depending on which
situation you were in
it could be a disaster or it could be
fine i mean that's what's so horrible
yeah i mean for me it would definitely
be the case i'd be able to get a decent
enough job to have
suitable healthcare at least for me
right but it's still just something you
have in the back of your mind you know
economy takes a downturn or whatever and
you don't have health insurance at that
time
absolutely what you do and it's just you
know it's a matter of writing out pros
and cons for living in different
countries as
we globalized people tend to do who have
the opportunity to move around and work
in different countries
right and you know when you're looking
at america compared to let's say the
netherlands or other places in europe
and you're ticking the boxes there's
just a lot of boxes left unticked
on the american side that kind of make
it look less
appealing which i think is a shame no
doubt about it i
i completely sympathize with you and uh
yeah i mean
where in the uk are you i'm in
birmingham
not alabama right right i've never been
but but certainly the uk has some
fantastic cities with high quality of
life and i uh i
understand why why people might hesitate
to abandon that
okay uh all right we lost them but uh
very very well made points
and i i appreciate them